ربما لا داعي لربط الاحزمه هذا الصيف
فاسعر تذاكر السفر اصبحت اكثر تكلفه السفر
الى اوروبا زادت اسعاره بنسبه 36 بالمئه
والى اسيا بنسبه 62%
لكن ما اسباب استمرار ارتفاع اسعار تذاكر
السفر جوا رغم انخفاض اسعار الوقود في
الاونه الاخيره السبب الاول يعود الى
زياده الطلب العالمي على السفر عما كان
عليه في عام 2019 قبل بدايه جائحه كورونا
والسبب الثاني فيرجع لارتفاع اجور
العاملين في المطارات خاصه في اوروبا اما
السبب الثالث فهو النقص في عدد الطائرات
فاساطيل الطائرات العالميه لم تعد كما
كانت عليه قبل الجائحه وهناك طائرات لا
تزال غير قادره على استئناف تشغيلها بسبب
نقص الايدي العامله من الطواقم وعمال
المناوله
كل ذلك يصب في مصلحه شركات الطيران فمع
ارتفاع اسعار التذاكر المتزايد وتراجع
اسعار النفط تشير التوقعات الى تحقيق تلك
الشركات ارباحا قياسيه بما يقارب العشره
مليارات دولار العام الحالي